as a parent you you know you watch your
children go through stages
and a business is very similar you watch
it grow through stages and there are
moments when you are needed everywhere
and you cannot take your eyes off that
business it's like having a toddler
right
you know you just you've got to be
everywhere you've got to be looking
you've got to be shaping and forming and
and helping that business to understand
where it wants to get to and what its
values are and what its culture is and
how we do things in this family
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders my guest today is sarah wood
co-founder and former ceo of unruly and
author of stepping up sarah wood is the
author of best-selling career books
stepping up she is an active angel
investor in early stage tech companies
a mentor at ucl hatchery and a board
member at
tech nation city ventures and the anna
freud
national center for children and
families which campaigns for young
people's mental health
sarah is an ambassador for the prince's
trust women supporting women program
and was awarded an obe for services to
technology and innovation
darawood welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you all the way from england
i'm really well and so pleased to be
here with you today michael
i'm looking forward to talking about
your journey both more than 13 years
with your company unruly
in the media space but also your time
now with tech nation in the under freud
center for children and family talking
about mental health
but also the author of stepping up with
leadership
leadership potential and and so many
different things that we can
that we can talk about i do want to get
started with unruly because
i i don't meet many people that spend
more than 13 years
working on a company that they founded
and there must be some really
fascinating lessons learned and
some insights that you've gained for
yourself that i as a young entrepreneur
can now enjoy without having to spend
the 13 years so hey so sarah what was
that
feelings like oh michael i love the way
you're focusing on the 13 years
uh you're right it's a long time um but
i guess it didn't feel like such a long
time
um because it was something that i was
really passionate about
uh and and i loved working with the
people
i was with and i think i know this is an
absolute cliche but it's really true
and the journey is as important as the
destination
so 13 years might seem like a long time
but it was a great ride and
really enjoyable and honestly the
hardest thing was leaving
and making the decision that that was it
yeah enough
enough time to move on uh learned lots
um
and again part of the benefit of taking
the company so far
going right from the start when there's
just the three of us myself and two
brilliant co-founders
and then taking it to series a growing
out into
multi-market selling it to news corps
was just
you know we saw so many different stages
of the business um and i think we
although for me that was my first time
as an entrepreneur um
experiencing so many different moments
of growth
was absolutely fascinating and i learned
a lot i learned that people are the most
important part of the business
yes product is important you do need
product market fit obviously
but actually you need people because the
product market fit isn't going to stay
you know you can't ever take that for
granted and you always need to be ready
to evolve ready to change
and you need the right people around you
to be able to do that
i also learned um the importance and the
benefits of failing up
so you know we made so many mistakes and
me personally in particular um
made so many mistakes along the way uh
and it was just a real relief to find
out that
this mistake plus that mistake plus
another mistake doesn't exactly equal
three mistakes
you put all those mistakes together you
learn from them
and then you can end up with something
that is kind of exponentially uh
larger and more interesting and exciting
than you ever dared imagine was possible
when you started out
what was that decision to leave what was
it like because you're there for 13
years you're watching grow i mean it's
kind of a child of yours
this project you know what how does that
feel like
um it was the right time uh and
i am a parent and i've got three
children and as a parent you
you know you watch your children go
through stages
and a business is very similar you watch
it grow through stages and there are
moments when you are needed everywhere
and you cannot take your eyes off that
business it's like having a toddler
right
you know you just you've got to be
everywhere you've got to be looking
you've got to be shaping and forming and
and helping that business to understand
where it wants to get to and what its
values are and what its culture is and
how we do things
in this family and but then there comes
a time when businesses grow
um and and you kind of feel that they
will be better
um with maybe a different environment or
a different set of people running it so
we sold it we sold it at a news corp and
in 2015
i'd stayed on to ceo for a couple of
years uh and at that point we were still
scaling
uh and i was still really enjoying it
but i could see that i wasn't
necessarily the right person to take it
on
for the next five years and i've always
believed that the customer
is key and you need to keep your
customers close as possible talk to
customers be with customers
and really make sure they understand the
product and help to shape the product so
it continues to stay relevant
and continues to grow market share but
at that point i had three children at
home
with lots of different needs and
customers all over the world
customers in cincinnati customers in
sydney customers in tokyo
and so the person that i was able to
recruit to take
on my role afterwards was amazing loved
being with customers was happy to travel
was never happier than when he was sat
with loads of different clients from all
over the world and that was just what
the business needed
so that that for me was was the main
reason and it's enabled me to
um kind of open up my eyes to other
ideas other projects
and so you're after you left you didn't
go and start another
13-year journey and at least not yet
but and it feels like you've taken a few
things that were important to you
personally and you
and you started dedicating your time to
a bunch of these causes and they're and
they're not the same
and i see quite quite a few of them that
are they're very different
what what what is going on there so how
what how do you decide not to spend your
time
and what are the things that are really
important to you
oh it's such a good question um and
well actually it's a brilliant question
and i spend a lot of my time thinking
about how to spend my time
uh because how you spend your time and
where you spend your money
basically define who you are um
where do you put your attention where do
you put your energy where do you put
your love where do you put your
intelligence
where do you place all that where do you
bring it to bear
that's all about where you spend your
time right um so i i do think about that
a lot
and then funnily enough in the last year
of unruly um i spent a lot of time
thinking about the legacy
thinking about the company we'd built
the people that had helped to build it
how awesome they were and what an
interesting culture we'd build because
it was a very diverse culture
people from all different backgrounds
skill sets personality types were able
to flourish and take on fantastic
positions of leadership
um and that led me to write the book so
i wrote a book called stepping up
um and it was in a sense a manifesto for
a more diverse leadership styles and
also more modern leadership style making
sure that people now
when they leave they lead with empathy
understanding and with a digital mindset
and with an entrepreneurial mindset
but it was also a love letter to unruly
and all the people there
and it was an attempt to kind of capture
a lot of the magic
so honour the past actually is something
i feel really strongly about
uh and i think before you can move
forward you need to be able to honour
the past
so this was very much doing that and
then um
i guess i'm a curious person i i just
love
different things um and i love being
part of lots of different things
so that i can connect dots in
interesting ways uh and spot patterns
um and bring expertise from over here to
over there
um so a good way of doing that um when
you're an exited founder
uh is becoming an investor uh and
investing and so putting your money
where your mouth is
and investing in companies that you
think are important companies that you
believe in and that you share their
values
so that's been one strand of work and
i've absolutely loved that
and wow at the moment it's incredible
you know this year in particular
uh there's just been a real resurgence
of tech startups and scale ups uh so
it's a brilliant company
and that is founded by uh former unruly
a brilliant former and really cool cat
jones
uh and it's slow travel flight free
travel and so that i'm really passionate
about that
and i seem to invest in a lot of snack
foods which have nothing to do with tech
but
i do like crisps and that is that is a
well-known fact about me
uh i love eating all sorts of crisps and
snack foods so
it's just a fun thing these are products
that bring me joy
um and people um that i have great
confidence in because i can
i can see their expertise i can see
their passion i can see their ability to
build a team
and then female entrepreneurship oh
sorry sorry what was she gonna say
that's exactly what i was about to ask
yes yeah well that's so that's one
strand the investment
um and then there's also uh female
entrepreneurship uh which i feel
really strongly about we need more
female entrepreneurs and more female
tech entrepreneurs
and more female tech entrepreneurs that
are scaling their companies and we do
have some fantastic women
in the industry lots more than you would
realize um but we still need more and it
is still
tremendously hard if you're a female
tech founder to secure uh funding
um and that needs to change um so
just being part of um movements and
and missions um that helps empower women
um and especially women in business uh
has been something i've really enjoyed
um so i'm an ambassador for the prince's
trust women's supporting women
and i spend a lot of time with
individual entrepreneurs and female
entrepreneurs just just chatting to them
and it's not really mentoring i'm not a
mentor type of person
it's more just having a coffee and just
seeing where they're at
and understanding what they're up to and
i just love talking to people
and especially talking to people
one-on-one when they are well you can
give them your full attention
uh and they give you their full
attention and it's just amazing the
ideas that come out and
the problems that can get solved just by
talking them through
i guess that brings me to the third
strand which is mental health
uh so so many of the founders that i
talk to
whatever stage of the journey actually
whether they're just starting out
whether they're in the throes of scaling
or or whether they're facing the angst
of exiting you know wherever they're at
um it's it's a real journey in terms of
mental health when you're an
entrepreneur
and and entrepreneurs are actually just
starting to talk about this because
you know historically if you're an
entrepreneur you're supposed to be
always on right you know what it's like
you're supposed to be full of energy
you're supposed to be
um workaholic working 24 hours a day as
much as you can to get things done and
cheat up the team
and that's you know that has it that has
its place and you do want to be
energized but
i think you have to be careful as an
entrepreneur because we only have
a limited amount of energy um and it's
about being careful
how we spend that energy and being as
careful with our mental health
and our emotional well-being uh as we
are with our you know with our business
and as we are kind of looking at our
balance sheets and looking at our teams
just taking the time
uh to make time for ourselves and get a
sense of perspective
and anna freud um is isn't related to
entrepreneurship but it is a fantastic
charity
that works with children um and their
families and teachers
and the professionals that surround
children and help them protect their
mental
health and i i think that is where it's
never been more important and we've seen
that this year
we've seen mental health issues
ballooning
as a result of covid so being part of a
charity that's helping
to be the solution to that problem
helping to build resilience in children
and their families i think is
is absolutely important it's just it's
such a privilege to be part of that
organization
so as you're part of that organization
and you also get to talk to a lot of
people you're also an inspiration for
many many people
i'm sure both both female entrepreneurs
but also
no male entrepreneurs as well i can and
what have you observed i guess you know
as a young entrepreneur and
speaking to other young entrepreneurs
what have you observed to be some
interesting
you know either patterns that are
happening or things that we can do
to either you know better sustain our
mental health over time
or better you know stepping up and
leading and embracing our potential
what have you learned meeting a lot of
these people that i could take with me
on my journey
um so you're doing a lot of these things
already michael you're
absolutely in the right place so in
terms of stepping up
and fulfilling your potential um it's
about having a vision
uh and where vision actually isn't
necessarily knowing where you want to
get to
but about being open to the future and
open to looking around and seeing what's
there
and being curious about what's there and
the brilliant thing
about being in tech is give you 10 years
20 years 30 years experience
well that's great to have but actually
you can come in with nothing
and you can be somebody and you can have
a fabulous fabulous company and you can
do that in a few months time
so actually the the pace of change
really works your advantage if you're
someone who's stepping up and it's
prepared to put in the time and the
energy um to look around and see what's
there
um and then just as important that as
that is as the people that you surround
yourself
with the votes i call it in my book i've
got the framework the five views
and votes is a really important element
of that it's making sure that you carry
people with you
um and building networks whether that's
professional networks personal networks
and certainly i'm really i found the the
informal networks of other cos when i
was zero
around me were just so valuable uh and
they were helpful
for stepping up because i learned a lot
from them but they were also helpful for
building resilience
uh and helping to keep me a little bit
calmer
and helped me to understand that
everybody's businesses were going wrong
all the time that at every point we were
all struggling to hire
every point we were struggling to rent
the right space
at every point we were fighting and then
losing product market fit and a
heartbeat
and having to pivot the product it was
just all our experiences
and kind of understanding that and
knowing that's normal
um just helps to ground you a little bit
more
the other thing i learned was that the
entrepreneurs who
um make the time for their families and
make the time for their friends
uh also uh are much better at going the
long haul
and for me one of the reasons i think 13
13 years
yeah it seems like a long time but
that's when i was bringing up my kids at
the same time
um and they always brought a sense of
perspective
and whether it's your children whether
it's your puppy um
whether it's your parents your friends
whatever it is uh having that sense of
perspective and understanding that well
this is just work but over here well
this is family
uh and these are the people that are
going to be with you for the journey of
your life
and making sure that you continue to
invest in them helps bring perspective
and then a black sense of humor or any
sense of humor
uh i think is often what
what i see with entrepreneurs who choose
to do it again and again they've got the
perspective
and they just have a little bit of sense
of humor about it you know
things are going to go wrong but you're
just being
able to kind of chuckle at your mistakes
um
chuckle when things go wrong and move on
i think is really important and it's
good for the team as well because when
the team see you chuckling
and when the team see you smiling when
the team see you're not tearing your
hair out
yeah that helps everybody i want to
pause for a second
at what you said before about this
moment of reflection and dishonoring the
past
this this idea do you do that also
within these 13 years do i i now you
have
the books that's been stepping up and
and and you're you
it sounds like you're very very
reflective but as you're going through
the entrepreneurial process
up until the acquisition do you do you
feel like you honored the past or you
managed to celebrate
the the victories along the way
so i'm not sure i was so good at
honoring the past um
enjoying and celebrating the present
which is another thing
i think is really important uh yes we
were always we we were good at that
um so making sure that when small wins
happened we celebrated them um always
because uh otherwise i just think
it would have been too relentless so yes
we would celebrate the small wins
um and and also you know i would often
kind of renew the contract with myself
at regular moments
um so i would always be reminding myself
am i in the right place
am i here because i want to be here um
is there something else i should be
doing
not just like is there another meeting i
should be in but is there an is there a
different vocation
is there a is there a different place
where i where where my skills and
talents should be
being channeled um and and i
always felt confident that i was in the
right place until i didn't
um and then there was just that one year
when i came to ask myself those
questions
and i wouldn't wait a year to ask them
either i would be asking them
often on a monthly basis sometimes more
often is this still the right place
um and having and constantly reminding
myself and i do i would say this to any
entrepreneurs
you'll hear most of us not all of us but
most of us are here through choice
um and that's a real privilege to be
able to choose a career
uh and to choose to do something that we
love and yes it's gonna be hard and yes
you'll make financial sacrifices and
probably family sacrifices but we're
here by choice
and in the morning when i used to cycle
into work and i would i would have
dropped off my kids at school
and you know loads of mums don't get to
do that there are a lot of moms who have
to go out so early in the morning
they don't see their kids and i always
used to be so grateful for that and then
as i was cycling in i would see people i
would see the cleaners i'd see the bin
men i'd see people who'd been at work
actually for three or four hours
uh i used to think wow now that's a
tough job you know my job is a breeze
compared to that
i just cycle into an office get a coffee
uh have some really interesting
conversations with people build some
cool watch some cool ads
um and you know that was that's joyful
and constantly remembering that on a
daily basis
remembering that i'm doing this through
choice and even when the days seem
difficult
remembering that the long-term goal is
really important because you're not just
building for the present you're building
for the future
and as a parent you're really aware of
that wanting to show my daughters that
they can do this
wanting to show anybody you know i knew
nothing about advertising or technology
or business
but became an ad tech entrepreneur um
and you and anybody can do that
and if they have that passion and
interest and they're prepared to work
and learn
um and learn learn from other people and
take other people on that journey you
know that is open to everybody
that it sounds incredible and and i love
the insights and i
i most of all i love that the reflective
piece of it and this honoring the past
which at the end it's
you know i i just i'm leaving with that
statement and i think that that's a you
know that's just very very cool
sarah i really want to thank you for
coming 20 minutes go by very very fast
but i do want to make time for a few
short questions about you and about your
your own
personality and and i'll start off with
easy
favorite subject in middle school or
high school
english literature every time it's what
i ended up doing my degree in i love
reading books
love talking about books love thinking
about books i love it
and one of your role models somebody
that inspires you
in one way or another i'm not going to
say one person because it's
all the people around me and i think
that's really key
um i don't think it's sensible to fixate
on one person
you just if you're lucky you'll have
fantastic parents siblings friends
co-workers and i always try and learn
something from the people that i'm with
they're all extraordinary um so it's
just kind of finding the extraordinary
in the people around you
and then aspiring to that i love it
and what are three words that you would
use to describe yourself
um
energetic um thoughtful
i spend a lot of time spend a lot of
time with these bad boys wow
wow i i definitely you know it's amazing
how within 20 minutes i can already
completely in you know intrinsically
believe the three words that he chose
for yourself
it's really amazing and sarah thank you
for for the wonderful work that you're
doing both with them really but now as
you know serving as an inspiration and
whether you know it's called mentorship
or
or whatever it in the end it's that it's
that inspiration
and it's that good-heartedness and and
and i think it's just it does a lot of
good for people so so thank you for all
the work that you're doing
and thank you for coming on stay safe
and stay healthy
thank you michael take care have a
lovely afternoon bye now
you